[Musique]
bonsoir l'émission ce soir est consacré
à jérusalem à l'histoire d'une ville
dans la tourmente du 20e siècle comme
vous le savez depuis les accords de
washington à septembre dernier le sort
de jérusalem est toujours suspendu donc
depuis 1917 jusqu'à nos jours nous
essaierons de restituer l'histoire de
cette ville sainte mais malgré
l'exaltation de 7 5t le poids des armes
n'a jamais cessé avec deux historiens
l'un palestinien elias sanbar directeur
de la revue d'études palestiniennes et
libanaises vie historien professeur à
l'université de tel aviv
trois fois sainte et 17 fois détruite la
ville de la paix a surtout connu la
guerre au cours de ces quatre mille ans
d'histoire de nabuchodonosor à begin les
plus grands stratèges lui ont donné
l'assaut objet de passion de fanatisme
et de convoitises le sort de jérusalem
après les accords fragile de washington
à l'automne dernier reste en suspens
[Musique]
au début du siècle jérusalem n'est
encore qu'un district de daman incluse
dans les provinces arabes de l' empire
ottoman l'entité palestine n'a émergé
que dans les années 1860 1870
depuis vingt-huit siècles déjà jérusalem
est capitale religieuse et politique du
monothéisme et depuis les 10 de statut
pour promulguer en 1852 par le sultan
turc
l'accès aux lieux saints et garantit aux
trois religions juive chrétienne et
musulmane
à la veille de la première guerre
mondiale la ville compte 75 mille
habitants 48 mille juifs dix sept mille
chrétiens et dix mille musulmans
[Musique]
jerusalem trois fois sainte jérusalem 25
fois détruite jérusalem qui fut plus une
capitale de la guerre que de la paix
alors avant de parler du statut de
jérusalem tout au long de cette émission
il serait bon peut-être elie barnavi que
vous puissiez rappeler pourquoi cet
enracinement symbolique religieux à
l'intérieur de ce fragment de terre de
palestine
sans doute parce que toutes les
religions besoin d'un lieu pour sa
racine et que jérusalem et ses lieux par
excellence pour les trois grandes
religions monothéistes effectivement
qu'ils sont et l'une de l'autre on peut
quand des poupées gigognes
pour les musulmans donnent le centre
sans doute mais devenue ville sainte
pour les chrétiens cité du paradis
c'était du paradis un coude si l'appel
cette ville la sainte pour les chrétiens
bien c'est le lieu de la passion du
christ bien entendu et pour les juifs
c'est le lieu unique c'est cette
alliance entre entre le texte peuple si
une pression si je les aime qui fait
l'essence même du judaïsme
et on comprend bien pourquoi c'est c'est
sur ces lieux que se sont cristallisées
toutes les patios toutes les folies
toutes les amours aussi
et que cette ville qui est ça c'est une
ville de paix céline des étymologies
brahic fantasy sans doute mais déjà ekwè
c'est important ce sans doute pourquoi
cette ville a été plutôt une ville de
galles que de payer le reste et j'espère
que soixantaine de sortir une ville
aussi il y à son bar où les pierres son
chevet très haut tout y compris
l'archéologie devient presque un acte de
guerre puisqu'un acte de ressourcement
historique qui appartient quoi
c'est vrai mais c'est une guerre récente
c'est vrai que depuis que cette ville
est au centre et l'allemand des enjeux
politiques il ya toute une démarche qui
est très très loin en réalité de
l'histoire mais qui s'habillent
de façon historique vous savoir un peu
en allant à la recherche d un vestige
vous pouvoir répondre à cette très
fausse question d'ailleurs savoir qui
était là avant l'autre et donc qu'il ya
une forme de légitimité millénaire mais
je voudrais ajouter également une chose
à ascq a dit elie barnavi qui me
semblent importantes celui d'être un
point où se focalise donc les croyances
les choix et une série de symboles
régionaux liés bien entendu à ces trois
religions monothéistes qui finalement
sont sortis de cette région là mais il
faut également y ajouter le fait qu'elle
a très longtemps et depuis longtemps et
est également un point qui focalisent n1
intérêts beaucoup plus large qui est
beaucoup plus lointain je dirais je
pense aux croisades je pense après aux
périodes coloniales ou même quand je
veux dire elle était au centre des
projets qui n'étaient pas forcément
religieux comme des croisades elle était
quand même utilisé comme symbole parce
que l'on savait que cela serait porteur
et il ya cette idée très forte et dans
ces trois religions est un peu dans
l'imaginaire
du monde
qui est un mythe qui est un baume et
finalement que ce serait une certaine
façon le centre de l'univers vous savez
qu'il ya beaucoup de photographes ils
voilà voilà il ya beaucoup de thèses
ce que je trouve tout à fait sympathique
et qui classe la natte lente id
d'autres
terrains des légendes telles ludique qui
en font le point de départ de la rose
des vents c'est le point focal d'où
partent les vents avant de dons clair
les l'oxygène et la vie leur nous allons
arrêter le vent de l'histoire 1917 vous
avez compris pourquoi est ce que c'est
le début du mandat britannique qui va
donc peser sur jérusalem
[Musique]
pendant la première guerre mondiale la
turquie se range du côté de l'allemagne
en 1917 l'armée britannique appuyé par
des détachements français et australiens
chasse l'occupant turc quelques semaines
après la déclaration de lord balfour
ministre britannique des affaires
étrangères qui préconise la création
d'un foyer national pour le peuple juif
dans une palestine redessinait pour la
circonstance la déclaration précisé que
cet établissement devait se faire en
respectant les droits civils et
religieux de toutes les communautés en
palestine
le pays va entièrement passée sous
administration militaire britannique
le 9 décembre 1917 le général anglais
allenby pénètre dans jérusalem à pied et
sans âme par respect pour la sainteté du
lieu
la résistance palestinienne s'organise
très vite dès 1919 ou ça casse'
alhousseiny le maire de jérusalem
manifeste au cours du premier congrès
palestiniens son opposition à la
déclaration balfour et réclame
l'indépendance pour une palestine arabe
il va être démis de ses fonctions par le
haut commissaire britannique surrey
roberts samuel qui en 1920 remplace
l'administration militaire
quelques mois plus tard hadj amine al
husseini cousin du maire limogé et nommé
mufti de jérusalem
[Musique]
où
jerusalem devient le siège de
l'administration anglaise la capitale
stratégique des organisations juives et
le centre du conseil musulman que dirige
le moufti
[Musique]
oh
si juifs et arabes semblent vivre en
bonne intelligence
le mur des lamentations devient l'objet
de sérieuses tensions qui feront dès
1921 une centaine de morts dans les deux
communautés
en 1922 la société des nations approuve
l'initiative de lord balfour et confie
au gouvernement britannique un mandat
sur la palestine
mais le foyer national juif et déjà
amputée de la transjordanie donné par
winston churchill alors ministre des
colonies à l'émirat chimiques abdallah
qui en fera son royaume
dès le début des années 20 et malgré les
restrictions imposées par les anglais
des vagues successives d'immigration
vont amener en palestine des milliers de
juifs qui viennent d'europe poussé à
l'immigration par l'antisémitisme qui
sévit dans leur pays
certains communieront dans un sionisme
porteur d'un idéalisme piot
[Musique]
l'unité de ce peuple pluriculturelle va
se forger autour de l'hébreu la langue
traditionnelle du clergé rénové est
imposée par eliezer ben yehuda
et puis la draille ogueyi chinois
mais le projet sioniste inquiète de plus
en plus les palestiniens arabes et en
1925 à l'occasion de l'inauguration par
lord balfour de l'université hébraïque
du mont scopus qui domine jérusalem des
arabes décident une grève générale de
protestation
[Musique]
mon
pour
la question d'orient agite les
chancelleries depuis le xviiie siècle
je rappelle que jérusalem était sous
administration ottomane de piques 1 116
les britanniques arrivent donc en 1917
et il faudra attendre trente sept pour
que le statut de jérusalem fasse
véritablement problème est lié à son bar
oui c'est à dire que dès le départ pour
les palestiniens d la guerre n'est même
pas terminé encore se pose déjà un
danger à leurs yeux qu'ils vivent comme
ceux là qui malheureusement s'est avérée
s'est réalisé de la raison qu'ils ont eu
peur qui dès le départ ils vivent ce
projet comme celui de leur remplacement
par une autre communauté donc il ya tout
de suite non plus aidé d'une
colonisation classique d'une occupation
mais d'un déplacement et d'un
remplacement et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
va se passer
il faut rappeler que le mandat le mandat
est une forme
douce de colonisation c'est détroit ford
de colonies si vous voulez c'est celle
qui est censée préparer les peuples de
la région l'indépendance est
explicitement effectivement la société
de la scion impose comme une obligation
au mandat britannique de préparer ces
peuples indépendance y compris et
surtout de favoriser l'émergence d'un
front national juif en palestine
effectivement à partir de ce moment là
il ya conflit entre entre deux
communautés si vous voulez ce conflit on
pourrait gloser sur la responsabilité
des uns des autres je crois qu ici photo
l'essentiel dès lors qu'il y avait deux
projets nationaux concurrents qui visait
la même terre il était il était fatal
que ces deux mots voix relationnel entre
en concurrence se fassent la guerre je
crois que c'était au centre de l'univers
de ce conflit avec au centre je vous
avais connu jérusalem est qui n'est pas
un problème particulier si vous voulez
jusqu'à jusqu'à c'est que l'idée ne
s'arrête pas là je suppose jusqu'à ce
que l'idée de la partition commence à
faire son chemin vers ce moment là la
communauté internationale commence à
imaginer un statut particulier aux
jeunes à l'être jusqu'à la junte par ty
de l'ensemble du pays personne ne songe
à couper jérusalem du reste du pays
c'est déjà vrai problème dans les années
[Musique]
l'immigration va se poursuivre pendant
les années 30 le vent mauvais qui
souffle sur l'europe double la
population juive de palestine qui
atteint 400 mille personnes au milieu de
la décennie
[Musique]
oui
devant ces arrivées massives
l'inquiétude arabe augmente déjà le 2
novembre 1929 12e anniversaire de la
déclaration balfour a été décrété jour
de deuil national par les palestiniens
arabes à jérusalem les tensions autour
du mur des lamentations s'intensifie et
les émeutes succèdent aux émeutes en
1929 en 1932 en 1933 faisant chaque fois
des centaines de morts de part et
d'autre des renforts britannique
toujours plus importants sont acheminés
pour rétablir le calme
ces images movietone de 1930 sont les
premières archives sonores sur jérusalem
[Musique]
les faits
en avril 1936 éclater la grande révolte
arabe contre les autorités mandataire et
contre la politique d'implantation
sioniste la grève générale et la grève
des impôts s'étendent sur l'ensemble du
territoire
devant cette situation explosive les
anglais nomment une commission denquête
chargé d'étudier les doléances arabe la
direction palestinienne tempère puis
décide de suspendre la grève
jerusalem devient donc un enjeu et le
terrorisme succède au terrorisme et les
palestiniens commettent des actes de
terrorisme
les sionistes commettent des actes de
terroristes et les britanniques ont les
situations extrêmement difficiles
il faudrait il faut ré consentante sur
les féras les mots avant de parler de
cette période je ne pense pas que cette
étape terrorisme c'était un mouvement
national qui réclamaient l'indépendance
et qui se heurtait à des unités
d'occupation coloniale qui était désarmé
envoyée
et de métropoles et ou acheminés
d'autres de par des dominions des
colonies britanniques
c'est une période très très riche en
événements très agitée dans laquelle on
ne peut pas dire que jérusalem et 10 ont
une finalité en soi mais jérusalem est
quand même le siège du gouvernement
central de siège de la puissance
coloniale est également elle est le
siège de la direction du mouvement
national palestinien qui de plus en plus
et 10 ont structuré autour d'un organe
qui s'appelle le haut comité arabe et
qui est dirigé par le mufti de palestine
[Musique]
le mufti a réuni autour de lui tous les
chefs de partis palestiniens arabes pour
former le haut comité arabe la grande
fête religieuse d'al nabi moussa sur la
tombe du prophète moïse est prétexte à
des démonstrations de force sous le
regard vigilant des anglais
en 1937 la commission royale de lord
pile publie ses conclusions et préconise
le partage de la palestine en un état
juif et un état arabe
jerusalem demeurant sous le contrôle des
anglais les sionistes accepte les
palestiniens refusent
police anglaise laisse entrer dans la
ville sainte aucun étranger sans oublier
malgré la surveillance qui s'exerce sans
relâche des bandits ont fait dérailler
un train ont pu mettre le 'pipeline'
la police et l'armée britannique s'est
pas de mettre un terme à l'activité des
terroristes
l'éxil du maire de jérusalem aux
seychelles et la fuite au liban du
mystique n'empêche pas les attentats
contre les officiels anglais et contre
leur installation
dans le secteur de jérusalem c'est le
propre neveu du mufti abdelkader al
houssi qui dirige la rébellion
cette grande révolte arabe appelé par
les anglais guerre des gangs ne cessera
qu'en 1939
sur la révolte j'ai quelques mots à dire
qu'ils sont très à mon avis tout à fait
essentiel pour comprendre cette période
cette période commence par une grève
générale nationale qui pendant six mois
place tout le pays en état de boycott
mais de boycott total et d'une certaine
façon la palestine toute entière sort un
peu de la sphère des rapports quotidiens
avec l'état du monde avec les
britanniques une espèce d'interruption
du contact et c'est dans ce cadre qu'en
37 sous forme de concessions parce que
le texte est assez intéressant le perdre
cette commission royale de lord piles
dont qui porte le nom de son chef
préconise à ce moment le partage le
partage de du pays en deux avec
un statut particulier pour gm à cause
des lieux saints c'est le lieu sénégas
est également quand même à mon avis dans
un peu l'arrière pensée britannique
l'idée de garder un bon pied dans le
centre de pouvoir
la même opinion elie barnavi sous
prétexte de sainteté on garde un
pied-à-terre militaire n'était jeu de je
ne pense même pas que ce soit vraiment
posé la question c'est tout
naturellement jérusalem après c'est
comme un coin pour le particulier comme
quelque chose qui appartenait un peu à
l'ensemble de la du monde dans
l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale
et il imagine degré statut particulier
pour cette ville avec un couloir
d'ailleurs qui va à la mer si solution
tout à fait irréaliste ailleurs enfin
c'est une idée qui fait son chemin et la
communauté internationale à restaurer le
moment dé lui ce que je voudrais ajouter
c'est que dans ces années 30 les deux
mouvements nationaux se cristallise et
atteint le point de non retour on voit
bien d'ailleurs l'évolution du mouvement
arabe qui étaient les premiers
affrontements entre justin la palestine
sont des affrontements ethniques
interethniques se passe à
29 pour la première fois c'est le
gouvernement britannique qui est qui est
plus possible la révolte
dans les volt arabe cela tout autant
sinon plus anti britannique anti juive
de son côté les joueurs s'organisent il
ya déjà eu noyau d'unités d'unités
militaires la ghana et tout cela pour
bien comprendre il faut songer à ce qui
se passe en europe c'est l'arrivée
d'hitler au pouvoir ou le sionisme n'est
plus seulement une idéologie énergies
nationales mais ça devient une urgence
absolue il faut bien voir que la
conférence d'evian sur les réfugiés
échoués que pour ce malheureux il n'ya
strictement plus où aller il n'est plus
à l'est était hélas c'est là que se noue
le drame véritable en fait des gens qui
aspirent alain palestine parce qu'ils
n'ont pas volé j'en attrape se ferme sur
nos neurones et mouvement national arabe
qui ne comprend pas très bien pourquoi
il faudrait payer les pots cassés pour
ce qui se passe en europe
l'incompréhension bien entendu total et
la guerre se poursuivra à partir de ce
moment là je dirais presque
naturellement des mots sur ce qui se
passe à 29
les anglais qui sont pris entre deux
feux et qui pratique la politique
d'apaisement en europe mais à l'entente
savent très bien qu'un jour ou l'autre
la guerre contre contre l'allemagne
nazie
plus ou moins inéluctable et qui ont un
besoin vital de ce bout de terre qui
fait jonction
contre l'europe entre l'angleterre et
les indes il est obligé de garder donc
d'avoir les bonnes grâces des
populations locales or le calcul est un
peu simple voire simpliste les juifs de
façon pas le choix ils seront du côté
des puissances alliées les arabes il
faut gagner et à ce moment là on voit le
glissement rapide des positions
britanniques les positionne de plus en
plus probables jusqu'à 39 où il ya un an
mais 39 la fameux livre blanc de 39 qui
limite qui liquide en quelque sorte
qu'ils annulent l'immigration juive en
palestine comme moment précis où en
europe la tragédie s'est offert le livre
blanc de 1939 limite au moment où le
nazisme étend son emprise le nombre de
juifs autorisé à se réfugier en
palestine et préconise un état
palestinien unique les deux camps le
rejette aussitôt
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
jérusalem devient un quartier général
des forces britanniques au moyen orient
le moufti réfugiés au liban cherche un
appui auprès de hitler tandis que les
forces de la haganah l'armée sioniste en
palestine s'engage dans le conflit aux
côtés des alliés à la fin des hostilités
chaque camp reprend ses positions les
arabes revendiquent la souveraineté
absolue sur la palestine et veulent
mettre fin à l'immigration juillet les
grandes voies de communication sont
gardés militairement cependant l'ardeur
des immigrés dans les pas diminué le
mossad agence clandestine sioniste
organise l'immigration illégale
encouragés par le président américain
truman qui demande le libre passage pour
cent mille réfugiés juifs les anglais
applique le livre blanc de 1939 et les
candidats à l'immigration sont refoulés
en europe ou internés dans des camps en
palestine et à chypre
en 1947 la sphère de l'exodus arraisonné
par les anglais qui décide de renvoyer
en allemagne ces 4500 passagers rescapés
des camps de la mort révèle le scandale
au monde entier provoquant une tempête
dans l'opinion internationale
à jérusalem les ultras de l'irgoun un
mouvement clandestin juifs organise la
lutte armée contre la présence
britannique en 1946 ils font sauter
l'hôtel du roi david siège de
l'état-major anglais faisant 51 morts
parmi les militaires la grande bretagne
qui souhaitent se décharger du problème
palestinien se tourne alors vers les
nations unies
[Musique]
le 29 novembre 1947 l'onu approuve le
plan de partage de la palestine en deux
états distincts jérusalem est déclarée
zone internationale
les juifs accepte ce nouveau plan de
partage les arabes refusent et passent à
l'action
à jérusalem comme dans toute la
palestine des troubles violents
provoqués par la nouvelle du partage
éclatent un peu partout en arabe et juif
sur tout centre commercial de la ville
le cinéma rex devient à son tour le
centre d'une agitation à descriptive
l'attentât de la rue ben-yehuda détruit
l'immeuble de la fédération juive du
travail tuant 54 personnes
aux extrémistes arabes répondent les
extrémistes juifs en avril 48 le village
de deir yassin situé à quelques
kilomètres de jérusalem est entièrement
rasé et ses 254 habitants massacrés par
une fraction dissidente de l'irgoun
l'action est condamné par l' agence
juive fuyant la guerre civile qui
s'installe la population arabe du futur
état juif va grossir les premiers camps
de réfugiés en jordanie au liban et en
egypte
pour les historiens juifs cet exode
palestinien a été encouragé par le haut
comité arabe et par les états arabes
pour les historiens palestiniens c'est
la politique de terrorisme menée par des
dissidents armés et non reconnue
officiellement par la direction sioniste
qui est responsable de cet exil massif
[Musique]
douala
il a le mans
je dois ma femme est de retour
jerusalem comme dans tout le pays
l'atmosphère est à la guerre civile
l'accès aux lieux saints arabes juifs et
chrétiens est encore libre mais plus
pour très longtemps et sous bonne
escorte
[Musique]
jean le temps
finalement si on voulait résumer le
mandat c'est très très simple la période
soit très riche très agité et très
douloureuse c'est des revendication
constante des destinées à arrêter
l'immigration d'arrêter la vente des
terres et d'avoir organe représentatif
de type démocratique s'appelait un
conseil ils ont passé le mandat réclame
un conseil législatif donc pour aller
vers l'indépendance de l'autre côté
puissance coloniale qui a toujours joué
les arbitres
apparemment impartiaux entre les deux
groupes pour le soir et perpétuer sa
présence et sa domination locale et
régionale et un drame qui se passe en
europe qui est ce ce génocide donc il
crée rien avec elie barnavi d'état leur
un grand mouvement de réfugiés pour
trouver refuge dans le sens le plus
immédiat du terme et où il faut quand
même et je tiens le diamant pas
seulement en tant qu'historienne en tant
que l'individu qui a pâti de ceux là
qui est que quand c'est ce pauvre
rescapés sont à la recherche d'un lieu
pour échapper au massacre toutes les
portes du monde libre se ferment devant
eux il faut bien le dire qu'il ya eu
quand même une hypocrisie assez
extraordinaire à l'époque d'avoir fermé
les portes les lois les lois de
l'immigration américaine sont
ahurissantes pour cette période les lois
anglaises également en pleine guerre et
donc le mouvement convergent un peu par
la force des choses la palestine après
la guerre c'est fini après la guerre ya
tout un mouvement qui est porté par une
autre
discours et est au centre de tout cela
il ya de fait que les palestiniens n'ont
pas n'existe pas de mon cv qui existe et
vous avez vu il ya des révoltes
constante mais il ne compte pas on ne
peut pas le prendre en compte et son
matière négligeable et c'est cela qui
est la grande déchirure palestinienne
est un peu le prélude à ce qui va leur
arriver en 48 qui disent appelant d'un
terme rabe qui est la nakba qui signifie
la catastrophe c'est l'année de la
catastrophe c'est un moment où tout d'un
coup tout bascule où les anglais qui
pouvaient être des arbitres hills pour
cela que les révoltes se font contre
l'angleterre c'est pas que l'on pense
pas qu'au mouvement sioniste est un
adversaire de parce qu'on pense que les
anglais sont suffisamment puissants pour
briser le mouvement sioniste s'ils sont
au même embêté donc il ya une espèce de
capsule triangulaires et où l'on
constate tout d'un coup que l'angleterre
qui n'est plus la première puissance du
monde les américains émerge après la
deuxième guerre mondiale
lâche le tablier je crois que cette
expression qu'on utilise remettent leur
tablier et hesdin de le dossier à l'onu
comme le disent c'est à ce moment que la
guerre va commencer
oui à ce moment là vers l abbé de l'onu
que la bière va immédiatement certaines
ag le départ forcé de centaines de
milliers de palestiniens il faut pas
l'oublier un pays qui coule qui est
selon l'expression une très bonne
expression tout d'un court couvert par
un autre
au terme d'un mandat qui a duré un quart
de siècle l'angleterre en la personne de
son haut commissaire le générateur à
l'âme cunningham abandonne la palestine
à son destin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le même jour david ben gourion proclame
la création de l'état d'israël et
l'indépendance du pays
heisman était le président et ben
gourion premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le lendemain 15 mai la légion arabe du
roi abdallah de jordanie commandé par le
britannique gold bacha pénètre en
palestine la guerre éclate la bataille
fait rage pour le contrôle de jérusalem
le 28 mai globe pacha s'empare de la
vieille ville le quartier juif est
abandonné par ses habitants
[Musique]
l'armistice d'avril 1949 coupe la ville
en deux d'un côté la ville nouvelle sous
contrôle israélien de l'autre la vieille
ville avec la quasi-totalité des lieux
saints sous contrôle jordanien il n'y a
plus d'état palestinien arabe pourtant
recommandé par l'onu
jérusalem-ouest et déclarée capitale de
l'état d'israël qui devient membre des
nations unies c'est là que s'installe le
gouvernement la knesset la cour de
justice et le grand rabbinat
désormais l'immigration est libre pour
les juifs du monde entier près de cent
mille d'entre eux vont venir s'installer
entre 1948 et 1967 mais pendant ses 19
années l'accès au mur des lamentations
leur sera interdit
[Musique]
alors est ce qui est un pays qui n'est
cependant qu'un pays coule et les
barnavi est attendu mais les 2 nestes à
la guerre ça il faut il faut bien
comprendre le sénat la communauté
internationale
se résout assez rapidement on l'a vu
dans les années 30 et ensuite en 1147 à
la seule solution raisonnable à ce
conflit qui était le partage
l'orsc de
deux peuples se disputer
on peut soit se battre jusqu'à ce
qu'elle disparaisse
soit se résoudre un compromis
territorial
et la solution raisonnable et est le
compromis territorial
malheureusement il a fallu du temps pour
que tout le monde comprenne de côté de
la barricade la communauté
internationale la décision de partager
l'onu a prévu la création de deux états
quel état juif les du derrière la
portion congrue et de l'état palestinien
pour des raisons qui tiennent à la
psychologie à la politique à la
politique est un des états arabes et je
crois que ce n'est pas là le lieu
d'essayer de disséquer exactement les
raisons de cette décision la partie
arabe a refusé d'endosser ce partage je
crois que le plus simple c'est à dire
qui ne voyait pas pourquoi ils
partageraient une terre qu'ils
estimaient être qu'il estivale il y
avait aussi du côté juif un parti des
parties secteur d'opinion et de la
classe politique estimait que tout cela
nous apporterait à droite révisionniste
ne veulent pas non plus pourquoi il
faudrait partager mes enfants et le
court central des indépendants
gaullienne a décidé d'accepter ces temps
de partage qui était nettement
insuffisant et qui était très loin des
promesses de la rétention balfour et à
partir du moment où donc les arabes les
palestiniens et les pays arabes les
états à reconstituer refusé le partage
de la galette est inéluctable
le problème de réfugiés est un problème
naît de la guerre il n'y avait pas des
réfugiés avant bien entendu tout cela
pour dire que on en train de l'ordre
dans une logique dans une logique de
guerre dans une logique de guerre
d'affrontements qui il s'agissait
pendant très longtemps il s'agissait des
liquides et donc la présence la présence
juive
aristide qui était jugée juif l'état qui
était jugé artificiel de ce marathon par
les croisés venait tout naturellement
dans la propagande arabe et 7 et avoir
fait la preuve de sa vitalité il n'avait
pas du tout l'intention de se faire
passer pour pour un avatar des croisés
en même temps il ya eu ça il faut le
dire aussi il ay ay ay ay déni
d'existence de palestiniens tant que
groupe que green nationale et de réfuter
était parfaitement symétrique
l'encore c'est intéressant de voir
comment un cycle historique s'achève par
la reconnaissance mutuelle qui va bien
au delà des péripéties de la politique
ça il faut bien comprendre quelque chose
qui va très loin qui va très
profondément dans cette espèce est en
capacité à éliminer l'autre en tant que
groupe international et finançant chi
minh de nouveau vers la solution qui
était là depuis les années 30 carole à
l'emmener l'ont peut-être ainsi que les
choses étaient s voyez c'est la sagesse
des humains est toujours un peu tardive
mais nous allons peut-être continuer à
suivre le fil chronologique une fois un
poids et rapides quand même parce que
cette histoire de la guerre de 48 est
crucial et elle déborde très largement
des relais les débats historiques entre
israéliens et palestiniens on a besoin
de vous dire que c'est un des points
bien que je sois d'accord sur beaucoup
de choses que l'hiver n'avait dit mais
là nous divergeons assez assez d
sensiblement et c'est un fois un manque
de percussion que jeudi encore qui
dépasse le débat historique le fait que
des réfugiés sont un peu les
conséquences d'une guerre parce que nous
savons que la quasi-totalité de réfugiés
de 48 sont sortis de palestine avant que
nantes le premier soldat arabes en
palestine donc l'état des refuges
existait déjà à la veille du 15 mai le
pays est déjà vide ça c'est un point
quand même très factuel il ya de grosses
conséquences pour savoir si c'est
précisément les conséquences ou un
préalable à l'entrée des armées arabes
la deuxième chose qui est également
présent j'aurais de la guerre civile qui
commence effectivement avant que les
éclairages que les horizons les pour
cela éclate en eau la deuxième chose qui
est quand même très importante c'est que
qui a disparu subitement de toutes les
archives et bien que cela existe mais
c'est que lors des débats sur le plan de
partage c'est vrai qu'il ya un refus de
partager est exactement comme comme vous
l'avez défini sur la base pourquoi
partager ce qui est de toute façon notre
pays mais il ya également dans le
dernier discours prononcé à launay en 47
et vous savez de 47 à 74 plutôt destiné
à nous se présentera à launay pour
parler c'est un vide total c'est un fait
qui reviendra en 74 4 la dernière voix
qui s'expriment lors des débats sur le
partage de la matinée au comité arabe
ait jeu marseillais dans son discours
sur le partage dans le même texte refuse
le partage des propos de la citoyenneté
à tout le monde qu un état commun et
c'est bien dommage mais c'est pas
innocent que cette portion de discours
est subitement disparu de tous les
textes on la retrouve jamais dans les
livres d'histoire alors il ya 120 si
vous le voulez bien nous allons
retrouver le fil chronologique nous nous
situerons donc à jérusalem à l'aube des
années 60 la ville est divisée d'un côté
l'administration jordanienne de l'autre
l'administration israélienne
depuis la partition de 1949 et
palestiniens exilés peuvent une fois par
an retrouver leur famille restée en
israël mais les juifs n'ont plus accès
au mur des lamentations qui se trouve
côté jordanien comme presque tous les
lieux saints
c'est côté jordanien que le pape hall 6
est reçu en 1964 par le roi hussein
jetair unique au monde par les grandes
heures des événements d'une telle a été
le théâtre
entre mes supplications se lève vers
dieu pour tous les hommes
croyants et incroyants
et nous y incluons volontiers les fils
du peuple de l'alliance
shalom salam
c'est là encore que se tient la même
année le premier congrès de l'ol paie
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine à l'abri des murs qui séparent
[Musique]
en 1967 eq l'attaqué à décision et le
début des hostilités
jérusalem la ville partagée était devenu
l'enjeu d'une bataille acharnée les
bombardements terrestres allait causer
de graves dommages tant dans le secteur
israélien que dans le secteur jordanien
[Musique]
mais après deux jours de lutte des
troupes israéliennes prenait possession
du secteur jordanien de la ville sainte
[Musique]
la ville est réunifié et suivant
l'exemple de moshe dyan la population de
jérusalem ouest peut à nouveau se
recueillir au mur des lamentations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la décision d'un excès jérusalem fut
prise le 11 juin 1967 jérusalem enfin
réunifiée vous étiez là donc nous avons
un historien acteurs de l'histoire
pourrait vous nous raconter ce qu'on lit
dans les livres à savoir une très grande
joie pour les israéliens tout petit
acteur de l'histoire un facteur sous
uniforme
et une campagne brève extrêmement
violent il fallait prendre la ville sans
l'abîmer il fallait il fallait la
prendre sur des troupes
excellente sur le tout les aguerris la
légion la légion jordanienne
et
ça a été fait et là il ya eu une
formidable explosion de joie ça faisait
longtemps que l'ouvrier avait et nous
avons été heureux que vous c'est nous
allons offrir l'occasion
et on appris au l'appui cette ville et
on l'a réunifiée effectivement très
rapidement on a fait tomber les
barrières les mieux les fils barbelés il
ya eu pendant un bref moment il fait un
joueur le 29 juin croit il ya eu et
journée la réunification de jérusalem
est là la foule l'a effectivement
fataliser j'étais là je me souviens je
me souviens de cette de cette foule qui
allaient destin ouest d'ouest en est et
qui se mélanger à la porte de damas
football enfants il est vrai aussi que
la propagande jordanienne présenter les
juifs comme des brutes sanguinaires et
comme des violeurs des massacres en
puissance d'occupation était
correcte ou incorrecte web au début et
il n'y a pas eu de pillage il n'y a rien
de tel et la suprise dans ma foi il ya
eu ce moment extraordinaire de joie pure
déjà purée on s'est dit mais même les
moins naïfs même plus sceptiques se sont
dits ya peut être moyen de vivre
ensemble dans une ville de jérusalem
enfin pacifiée et bien entendu bien
entendu il a fallu déchanter parce que
toute occupation pour libérale qu'elle
soit et n'allez pas moi une occupation
est ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que
israël a offert
aussitôt la citoyenneté israélienne aux
résidents de jérusalem
les citoyens razzano
ne se sont pas précipités seulement
qu'on puisse dire et c'est ainsi que de
fil en aiguille est arrivé à avoir ou
ville réunifiée en principe mais qui
restaient divisés en fait
[Musique]
après la guerre des six-jours jérusalem
réunifiée repasse sous contrôle des
israéliens le libre accès à tous les
lieux saints est rétabli pour tous y
compris pour les ressortissants des pays
ennemis c'est la pax judée à une paix
bien fragile qui ne réussira pas à
apaiser les tensions entre les deux
communautés
le moyen orient est un véritable baril
de poudre l'incentive de la vénérable
mosquée d'al aqsa à jérusalem a enflammé
tout le monde arabe
en arrêtant très vite le boutefeu un
jeune illuminé de 28 ans qui a avoué son
forfait le gouvernement israélien s'est
efforcé de calmer l'effervescence des
musulmans
[Musique]
la vieille ville juive détruites après
la guerre de 1948 et reconstruite et une
large esplanade et crée devant le mur
[Musique]
devant l'afflux croissant des immigrés
la ville s'étend hors de ses murailles à
l'est comme à l'ouest
que ce soit sur les collines ceinturant
la capitale de l'état hébreu au coeur de
la vieille ville
cette politique d'implantation qui
s'effectue en violation des décisions
internationales et violemment critiqué
par l'ol paie
jérusalem qui au début du siècle ne
comptait que 60000 habitants en compte
aujourd'hui 5 185 il donc quatre cent
trente huit mille juifs et 155 mille
arabes
après la guerre du kippour le 19
novembre 1977 anouar el sadate est reçu
à la knesset il est le premier dirigeant
arabe à reconnaître l'existence d'israël
il se pose en interlocuteur et amorce le
dialogue de la paix je vous le dis
devant le monde entier nous acceptons de
vivre à vos côtés dans une paix
permanente basée sur la justice
en 1981 jérusalem est définitivement
annexé par l'état d'israël est inscrite
dans la constitution comme capitale
éternelle aucun pays ne reconnaît cette
décision qui provoque la colère
immédiate des arabes les tensions ne
feront que s'aggraver entre extrémistes
des deux camps
[Musique]
en octobre 90 la fusillade de
l'esplanade des mosquées fait 21 morts
parmi les palestiniens et provoquent de
nouveaux troubles dans la vieille ville
sous l'oeil impuissant des observateurs
de l'onu
le 13 septembre 1993
yasser arafat et itzhak rabin conclu des
accords de paix à washington les frères
ennemis se réconcilient et jérusalem
pavoise la reconnaissance réciproque et
simultanée entre les deux peuples
commencent à se concrétiser
mais les derniers événements dramatiques
démontre que le cheminement vers la
cohabitation pacifique reste long et
ardu le temps de la paire est suspendu
il faut encore construire l'essentiel la
réconciliation et la définition d'un
statut pour jérusalem
maintenant il va falloir fabien va
falloir passer pour le maroc et voilà
comment on pourra continuer à
vivre ensemble puisqu'il n'est pas
question effectivement de la vie de
l'église et la ville et en même temps
permettre
quelques 150 milles 12 a même une
existence non seulement communautaire
existence nationale voilà les pôles du
problème et c'est ce sont ces ces deux
contre un qui va vouloir réconcilier
c'est possible à mon avis les accords de
paix de washington ont soigneusement
pris soin d'exclure le statut de
jérusalem qui cependant devrait être
réglé d'ici une période de trois ans
comment voyez vous l'avenir de jérusalem
est bien seul plusieurs choses et l on
peut partir uniquement du distinction
entre 2 2 ou d'une mise en parallèle
entre deux termes elie barnavi à
utiliser le
mou de la ville réunifiée
il faut bien comprendre que du point de
vue des pas destiné à ce même instant
cette ville était désormais occupés donc
il ya une occupation une réunification
qui ce qu'on fasse c'est comme ça que
cela est perçu maintenant je crois que
dans toute négociation il faut il faut
casser les choses à deux niveaux nous
avons le niveau strict de la négociation
elle même c'est à dire finalement jeu
qui se passe selon des règles elle
établit avec un certain nombre de points
de référence les références de la
négociation sont des résolutions de
l'onu qui sont la résolution notamment
242 qui inclut l'occupation des
jérusalem dans l'occupation des
territoires occupés en 67 bien sûr la
partie israélienne à une autre lecture
de cette résolution il est certain que
la le texte de référence est celui là là
nous avons des textes et le traité qui a
été signé le 13 septembre à washington
dans son préambule dit que le but de ce
traité de paix et la mise en application
de la 242 donc il faut y arriver grâce à
ce premier volet que le deuxième qui est
le plus compliqué quelques fois qu'on a
le droit il voit qu'on a la
reconnaissance qu'une paire est occupée
il faut qu'on voit quelle est
l'application des droits il faut passer
après aux choses concrètes
il se voyait municipal est compliqué je
vais vous dire gonna be vous grâce nous
va se passer concrètement il faut
certainement qu'il y ait un premier pas
pour ricky libre et les choses qui
soient précisément celui de la fin de
l'occupation pour jérusalem quitte après
c'est comme un préalable pour permettre
aux palestiniens de commencer à imaginer
ce jeudi imaginer la bonne escient parce
que je pense que c'est un dossier qui va
requérir contrairement au reste des
territoires occupés beaucoup
d'imagination il est très compliqué il
est très chargé c'est vraiment avec
l'imaginaire
difficile donc il va falloir faire
preuve de beaucoup d'imagination mais
pour pouvoir passer à l'imagination il
faut passer
incontournablement je dirais par
l'application du droit cercle pour
qu'ils aient un moment d'application du
droit en vertu duquel les deux parties
seraient aptes et justes libres et vous
pouvoir commencer à imaginer elie
barnavi a dit tout à l'heure qu'il était
possible pour lui d'envisager donc une
manière de vivre ensemble palestinien
israélien jerusalem répondriez vous avez
que jérusalem qui m'intéressent
j'appartiens à la génération des
palestiniens qui ont eu 20 ans en 67 et
moi mon grandes aspirations de long de
m'engager dans ce mouvement depuis
quelques années était
pas du tout les deux états elle était
réalisable mais mon inspiration mon
idéal à moi c'était un état pour tous
moi j'ai toujours milité pour un état
pour tous avec un statut de citoyenneté
et qu'on laisse à chacun la liberté de
ses croyances est sa religion et d
appartenance familiale clanique originel
ainsi de suite mais malheureusement
l'histoire ne s'est pas fait comme ça et
ce qui me semble aujourd'hui en train de
se dessiner est pour moi la meilleure
solution praticable mon idéal n'est pas
celui là mondiale est un état
démocratique et laïque
c'est sur ces paroles que va s'achever
cette émission alors rapidement
plusieurs livres pour continuer cette
discussion il y à son bar vous publié
ces jours ci un livre qui va être publié
aux éditions gallimard jeunesse est là
pour la première fois un travail
historique qui retrace l'épopée des
palestiniens dans la collection
découvertes je rappelle aussi que vous
êtes directeur de cette revue d'études
palestiniennes dont le dernier numéro
avec un olivier sur la couverture
l'olivier est un symbole de la paix
vient juste de sortir le numéro 50 et
puis je voudrais signaler un livre de
photographies et de mémoire avant lors
diaspora qui raconte l'épopée des
palestiniens de walid khalidi est un mot
qui ont le livre n'est pas de moi ce que
je les traduis pour connaître un peu la
voix la voix intime des palestiniens un
recueil de poèmes notre plus grand poète
qui est mahmoud darwish et qui paraît
également ces jours-ci logé à son
habitude et puis elie barnavi vous avez
publié une histoire moderne d'israël
qu'on peut trouver dans la collection
champs chez flammarion et puis une très
belle une très belle histoire
encyclopédique universel des juifs aux
éditions atlas achètent je vous remercie
la semaine prochaine nous nous
retrouverons avec un sujet totalement
différent nous reviendrons en france et
patrick rotman vous racontera en
compagnie de l'historien serge bernstein
une décennie de révolte 1963
1973 du concert de la nation jusqu'en
1974 la possibilité pour les jeunes de
voter
huit ans en passant par la contestation
politique et militante de mai-68 comment
les jeunes ont pris la parole à défaut
de prendre le pouvoir à la semaine
prochaine donc bon soir
[Musique]
m
oui